the anthem for the voiceless that's the
focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
practically overnight this is crazy the
singer's gone from unknown to number one
on the billboard charts and this is what
happened the unsigned artist breakout
hit it's called rich men north of
Richmond went viral online earlier this
month and now it's sitting in the top
spot on the Billboard Hot 100 he's the
first artist ever in history to reach
that Milestone with no prior history on
the chart in any form whatsoever
well an historic climb on the charts
that should be a wake-up call to these
out of touch Elites in politics the
entertainment industry who frankly
routinely write off or look down on half
the country there's all this damn
country does is keep on kicking them
down
lord it's a damn shame what the world's
gotten to for people like me people like
you wish I could just wake up and not be
true but it is
all it is
so weeks after we featured the song on
the angle The Today Show finally caught
up to the Groundswell not with bias but
with bewilderment
conservatives have rallied behind the
track it calls out wealthy legislators
in Washington D.C some are describing it
as raw and authentic and although on his
own YouTube channel he posted a video in
which he labeled his political views
quote dead center down the aisle
everybody is talking about this thing
well they're talking all right but it's
not all nice the venomous crew over at
CNN is clearly seething over the
breakout success of those establishing
their own counterculture well the left
is so used to having Monopoly aren't
they and music and in film theater even
Sports
that they start to sputter and fume at
any perceived encroachment by
non-worksters
liberal commentator Oliver Darcy over at
CNN described Americans as primed to low
the mainstream pop culture in the media
and that they are willing to open their
pocketbooks to Champion their politics
well that's true but Darcy went on to
warn that Anthony's success could spell
the end of a shared popular culture
similar to how the Advent of right-wing
talk radio and Fox News ultimately
spelled the end of a shared
understanding of current events okay a
shared understanding of current events a
shared popular culture what on Earth is
Mr Darcy talking about
now someone needs to break it to the
modern left
we did at one point have a shared
culture and year by year decade by
decade they mocked it they trashed it
and ultimately they destroyed it
and ever since powerful interests have
worked to supplant traditional American
values country Family Faith with a
radical sexual and political agenda
the principle of Tolerance just tolerate
everybody well that gave way to forced
acceptance
and in the process what do they do they
ruined the news business Walter Cronkite
wanted to be trusted by everyone
remember well then Dan Rather he wanted
to be known as an outspoken lefty well
they both got what they wanted
eventually an opening was created for
Rush Limbaugh and for Fox News
well they ruined education too test
scores they're plummeting Across America
standards are being lowered or even
eliminated the curricula bastardized
this spawned the homeschooling
phenomenon well they did the same the
film theater music fashion years ago in
one of my books I called it the
pornification of the culture well it's
pornified and too often now politicized
as well
and these performers they just can't
stop making fools of themselves
I have thought an awful lot about
blowing up the White House you know when
Donald Trump spoke at his inauguration
about American Carnage I assumed that
was something he was against not a
campaign promise the past four years
have left us as a nation diminished and
divided we are better than this America
is better than this
oh tell us about it so a vacuum has been
created all right at least half of the
country doesn't listen to those fools
and they they don't like what's
happening to our kids to our schools and
they certainly don't like what's
happening in most of our popular culture
they don't trust Hollywood they don't
trust the news media and they don't even
trust most politicians frankly in either
party
so what does this do this opens the door
to new voices and politics and new
voices in the culture who want to create
movements and in this case want to
create music and then films plays and
even businesses for the underserved
and as for the consumers what do they do
well they boycott woke nonsense at
places like Target Bud Light or they
support Outsider films like the sound of
Freedom or musicians like Oliver Anthony
that's their own form of protest
so are liberals really so clueless that
they didn't already know that the
culture was splintered and that they did
it
now I remember when they were urging a
boycott of their own of Chick-fil-A
because the CEO gave money to Christian
charities
but we Christians or other traditional
Americans what are we supposed to do
shovel our money to people who obviously
despise us
we're not supposed to try to create
alternative entertainment business news
channels
oh oh I get it sorry they're the only
ones entitled to protest and create
oh it was great when they were the only
ones right challenging the Old Guard the
Old Guard back in the 60s and the 70s
with their films and with their music
but when Oliver Anthony got nobody's
heard of strikes a chord with his song
it's seen as a threat
well news flash to the elites long
before Oliver Anthony country music
embodied the independent kind of
Kick-Ass American Spirit the working
class the Forgotten man and a simpler
way of life
Jason Aldean's uh try that in a small
town is reminiscent of Hank William Jr's
classic
I've got a shotgun arrival in a
four-wheel drive and a Country Boy Can
Survive
and then it was back in 1974 that Johnny
Cash released ragged old flag that was a
patriotic ode but liberals say that
they're triggered today when they see
too many American flags
athletes made Millions after refusing to
stand for the anthem so yeah there are a
lot of people out there who love the
country and they're ticked off and they
want their own space
but they're not going to find it at
Disney
they couldn't do a live remake of Snow
White at Disney without turning it
political
the original cartoon came out in 1937
and very evidently so
um there is a big focus on her love
story with a guy who literally stalks
her
weird the fact that she's not going to
be saved by The Prince and she's the
proactive one and she's the one who set
the terms
um is what makes it so relevant to where
we are today
relevant
where we are today is that Disney is
relegated to making live-action remakes
of their most storied animated films and
turning them into tedious spectacles
starring bubble head actors and
actresses who parrot liberal tropes and
of course directed by liberal adults who
think they're more talented than Walt
Disney himself
now let's see which the audience likes
better the original that Ms Zeigler
claims is so terrifying and outdated
or the 2024 version oozing with female
empowerment
so look you can have a common culture or
you can have a alienating left-wing
propaganda machine
but you cannot have both and that's the
angle hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else